hello everyone and welcome to the oven
carmichael show-- i am your host Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help I was out
late last night I was hosting a dance
party but chata party at one of the
companies that I've invested in and it's
great to see good companies doing well
and I want to see that for you as well
now before getting started I need to
welcome two new producers is a show
usually I'm with Zach and Courtney today
it's steve and Fernanda so I'm excited
to hope we have a good show hope
everything goes well this show is really
important today is extremely important
today I'm going to give you strategies
to not only save your business but help
you build the company that you deserve
and can be proud of instead of just
struggling to get by on the agenda today
I'm talking about how to turn a bad day
around do women get respect as business
owners if your business isn't where it
should be your fault and how to go all
in now if you're having a bad day bad
week by month you have to find a way to
turn it around running the business is
hard there's going to be peaks and is
going to be valleys you guys know what
I'm talking about there's some days when
you are on top of the world everything's
going really well you love everything
about your business and then you're
going to have the days where you feel
like you're just getting kicked on going
and then when you feel like nothing else
could happen you that's worse than
what's going on right now damn in your
face another huge problem and that's
part of running the business but you
can't let those down days EP down for
too long okay last week I had a bad day
it was wednesday i got on the call with
my book agent i'm working on this book
deal i thought i did a great job with a
new proposal she calls me up and slammed
me on it she said she hated it she says
my first suppose it was better to tells
not going in the wrong direction I
didn't fully understand all of her
feedback and was confused as to what to
do next I was frustrated I wanted to
make this thing happen and I hate
hearing that I'm going in the wrong
direction then I get on the call with my
media coach who's
having me for all the things I'm doing
on radio and saying I need to be better
pointing out all my flaws giving me
suggestions for what to do better and
for two hours I'm just taking it from
these people and it was all great
feedback but hard to take then it starts
raining outside and I brought my Vespa
to work and I didn't check the weather
report it was studying the morning now
i'm going to get stoked as they leave
for the afternoon so my day was not off
to a good start and i had an important
afternoon i had to film 14 videos that
afternoon and i needed to bring my
aching and you got to bring it for your
business to you have to bring your A
game for people to pay attention if your
business to grow you're not going to
watch my videos to farm on there saying
hey guys at seven I'm really down today
but you have to grow your business right
that's not going to it's not going to
aspire you and motivate you so what did
I do number one I got out of the office
I went to a Zumba class boom was like
Latin line dancing cardio get out of
your office do something to get the
blood flowing a little bit get some
perspective get some distance you'll
start to feel better number to go help
somebody I helped my dad I invited him
along for the class and he felt like he
wanted to have a little bit of fitness
in his life he wasn't in the best shape
so he came along with me to the class
and he's smiling and I see him at the
end of the class he had a great time
huge smile across the space tons of
sweat across his forehead and he said
thank you and that made me feel good you
know when you do things to help people
you'll feel better you'll have more
energy you would have put that back into
your business and the third thing I did
was go out and get some liquid
inspiration I went to my local starbucks
picked up some caffeine and sugar my
favorite drink right now is the caramel
ribbon Frappuccino and just gave me a
little bit extra energy so if you're
having a bad day try some of those
things get out of your office do
something active run the stairs go for a
jog go for a walk around the building
whatever it is to try to help somebody
out it'll make you feel better and three
of that field liquid inspiration get
some caffeine and sugar in you it'll
help turn your day around because you
eat it if you stay down for too long
your business will fail you have to be a
driving force of positive energy to keep
your business going we have to brenna on
the line to brenna where are you from
and how can I help I'm from Charlotte
North Carolina Charlotte all right
welcome to the program what's going on
thanks for the last seven years my
husband and I have had a landscaping
business and it's been at a standstill
for the last probably two or three years
we haven't been able to get any new
customers and will we lose customers and
we just want to find out what with what
can we do to you know expand our
business and just get it on the road cuz
why are your customers I think it is
usually the residential customers they
they just can't afford to pay us anymore
they can't afford anybody cutting their
grad paying someone to cut the grass and
then they're what they're doing it
themselves yes okay what is special
about your landscaping company well we
we take care of the the lawns pretty
good our customer service i believe is
very well I mean people tell us they
they really like our work and you know
we're there when we say we're going to
be there and we do it we do a very good
job I my treat yards like I treat my own
yard I love planting flowers when we
have been thought up a bit I grind all
that well yeah I'd do it just like I'm
doing my own I'm loving your passion
that's a great story that you want to
tell a business like yours word of mouth
is a fantastic way to grow it because if
neighbors are looking at their lawn and
they're seeing you know how nice it
looks they get jealous they want the
same thing we got to over-deliver like
crazy for people to talk about you you
know your customers they have busy lives
too if you want them to spread the word
you've got to do something above and
beyond to make them care so I'm just
thinking like landscaping business is
great there's a lot of competition it
sounds like you really care about your
business which is great I'm trying to
figure out what can you do
to make it better to make it so you can
over deliver like crazy so that people
will want to tell their friends about
you I honestly don't know we've actually
started attending bidding conferences so
that we can you know be a contract with
the city so that we can just enlarge our
customer base as we we mainly want to
deal with commercial account and not so
much residential okay and I have to be
honest that's because that's where the
most money is it's where a lot of money
is but is it high margin for you lot of
times in which city can be hard to make
a buck off of oh yeah it is pretty hard
and we're small and I kind of feel like
it's just too competitive death death is
where I'm our mind has been you know
thinking that we needed to go shoot for
the stars basically how important it is
for you like if you're not if you don't
get new business is your company in risk
of failing I honestly think so because
for that but alas well for every year
we've been open we found a loss on our
taxes listen it's not really profiting
us a whole lot but we really want to do
we want to be entrepreneurs and own our
own business I don't know if it's just
something different we could try the
possibly because we don't want to just
let it go we don't want Turner lose we
put a lot in this is important because
this is your livelihood Yeah right like
this has to work and it's both you and
your husband together in this thing
right there's no other any coming in
right now it's not you've got to find
something that really separates you from
everybody else I love your story I love
the whole you know we're family business
I treat this like it's my lawn I really
care about this have you promoted that
angle you know actually we haven't when
talked about it like that know that
other people we just if you came to me
and you said hey I cut grass then I'm
going to compare you to you know my my
neighbors who might do it or myself
might do it
or other companies like you're not
really standing out but if you say hey
we're a family-owned business I really
care about lon and flowers I'm making a
house look nice and I'm going to treat
your house like it was mine or your
property like it was mine that starts to
get me interested yeah I think it's a
way you can really stand out okay I
happen I've never thought about pizza at
that kind of way okay well I can you try
it yes I definitely will is that
exciting yes it is okay and that gives
me something to think about this is
important it's really important as this
is your whole business okay and I really
want you to put that in and put that
effort in okay all right thank you so
much no problem thanks for calling in
and everybody listening it's so
important for yourself Incubus your
story that'll make people want to do
business with you it's your way to help
stand out especially when this is your
only way to make money and you have to
make this work and the other day I got
an email that really bothered one of my
readers wrote an anemic Charlotte he
said why are ladies not taking seriously
as business owners it bothered me for a
number of reasons but first off the
reason why she's not a successful she
can be is not because she's a woman
she's not getting respect because she's
a woman it's because she doesn't have
the confidence and it bothers me that
she has this limiting personal belief
that says I'm a woman so I can't be
successful okay and too many people
right in calling to this show hit me up
on Twitter Facebook YouTube with
limiting personal beliefs this problem
is not because she's a woman it's
because she doesn't believe in herself
and we all have these big dreams for
ourselves these big ambitions for the
life that we want to live and there's
this little voice in the back of her
head that says you can't do it you can't
do it because fill in the blank there's
a reason there's a limit in person I
believe that holds all of us back and
you need to stomp it out you need to
crush it down because it's always going
to hold you back from building the
company in your dream it's always going
to hold you back I know a ton of women
aren't
preneur how is successful who have great
businesses we don't take crap from
people who demand and command respect
and I know a ton of guys who do the
complete opposite they have crappy
businesses they don't get any respect
you don't have a fantastic product or
service it has nothing to do with if
your man if you're a woman if you're in
another country if you have an accent if
you have a disability if you don't have
an education as long as you believe
those things will hold you back then
it's going to hold you back they're just
limiting personal beliefs that have
nothing to do with your success as an
entrepreneur as a business owner you
chart your own course and as long as you
believe you can do it then you can do it
the second thing that bothered me she's
not being all women in together and I'm
worried I was a message that this is
sending because I don't want my
daughters my sister's my wife thinking
that they can't be successful because
they're a woman they could start a
business but it's going to be a lot
harder for you because you're a woman
that's not the message we need to be
sending if you're an entrepreneur it's
going to be rough it's going to be hard
no matter what background you come from
but if you want it you can go get it as
soon as you change the story you're
telling yourself you will change your
business and you will change your life I
have Sharon on the line Sharon where are
you from and how can I help I'm actually
from Chicago Illinois little guy oh
thank you I actually work in a nail
salon okay and I'm actually thinking
about you know striking out on my own
Bub's up my own nail salon and was just
you know wondering what would like the
first step b was will accept I need to
take in establishing my own nail salon
this is drea you excited yes I am I am
really really excited I know that my
location is everything and okay so this
is what's really important
have you ever started a business before
no okay and that's fine now everybody's
got to start somewhere but it's really
hard to make a business fly it's great
that you're already working at a nail
salon what i would do is try to get us
close to the owner as possible and learn
everything about that business so when
you're going on opening your own shop
you're not just being knowledgeable and
how to do nails but you're also
knowledgeable and how to run a business
right is there anything you could do to
help out the owner get to know them a
little bit more get to know their
challenges and how they hire people and
how they promote their business is a
project you can get involved in to help
out a little more um actually I have
been doing that I've been you know in a
temporary position nail Parsons fresh
managing you know her her nail salon
okay here early this is great yeah yeah
the next thing is we guarding I would
try to find a way to start part time
before diving in full time because a lot
of entrepreneurs they jump into a full
time they leave their job and they
realize his a lot harder than I thought
it was going to be and they run out of
money to run other funds and they have
to close down yeah so I don't want that
for you right I want to see this nail
salon take off for you and you've
already done a lot of the steps that
you've never run a business before but
you've already taken 11 steps that you
need to to prepare yourself the next
thing is actually just starting up on a
part-time basis can you think of a way
to do that yeah definitely um I mean how
do you do what can you do to stand
outside oh well first of all I need to
find some space I'm kind of like suck on
it where to open up the Swan what is a
good you know location to actually open
up the pond for all we know that would
this is a big danger you open up in the
wrong space it can sink your business
right now you can have the best service
but if your if your location stocks it's
going to be hard to make this business
work so a great way to try it out is
instead of going to a mall and getting a
location and signing a five-year least I
could think your personal finances to
try to partner up with a local business
who has a location already and offer to
do nails out of their location doesn't
have to be a nail shop another location
some other kind of store some other kind
of retail outlet that deals with your
kind of customers and work not at their
location part time so you can test you
can test it test out that location see
how you are as an entrepreneur is there
any Madame style in place you could you
could try out you know sublease from
somebody for a little bit or be part of
their store and do nails because so I
mean yeah there's a couple of places
that I could check into and see if they
will work that sounds like a great idea
because I was going to go the route of
you know I'm in a place and you know
doing a leaf and you know you don't do
that long oh my god because you could
Ali about to do that you can sink your
business you have to make sure you get
the right location this is this is
important this isn't like McDonald's
where if you up a new location and it
doesn't work whatever that's fine like
it's mcdonalds this is everything for
you right yeah but you pick the wrong
location you're sunk so it's got to be
important come out of that so I would
find like a hairdresser somebody who you
can you can take a spot out of their
store rent it for a little bit of time
the test of the location see if it works
and if it is if you're getting customers
and you're enjoying it and they're
loving what you do then when you open up
your location have nor clientele and you
know that that location works right yeah
okay thank you so much no problem good
luck i'm excited for you you're taking
the right steps around me tonight while
ok ok ok thank you good luck for
everybody listening hey if you're
looking up and opening your own store
it's one of the biggest failures of most
entrepreneurs you pick the wrong
location and you
shutting down is so important you gotta
think the right place start small but
renting out somebody else's location to
get going and if your business is not
where you think it should be then the
reason is staring at you and the face
mirror is your fault you can't blame
others for what's happening your
business and I get too many people who
call into my show who write me up on
email or Twitter or Facebook any of
those channels and they blame something
for why they're not successful they
blame their customers they blame their
employees they blame the government they
blame the economy if your business can
only do well in a good economy then you
don't have a business you have to be
able to survive through any economy
running a business is hard this isn't
some easy thing you just get up and do
and you have tons of success you have to
be able to survive all of those
situations and if something goes wrong
which it is you have to fix it nobody's
coming to fix it for you some of the
best businesses in the world were built
in recessionary times and you can't
blame a bad economy or your inability to
get out there and drive business okay
you have to be better you have to invest
in yourself and when you take
accountability and realize that you are
the problem and you were the only one
who's going to fix it that's when your
business starts to grow I got an email
from one of my readers Donald who had a
housing construction business and his
business fell apart in the housing
crisis and now he's not doing anything
and he's blaming the economy for his is
luck and you know what it was about
economy and still is but people are
still spending you have to get out there
and hustle and turn this thing around
until Donald listen like you can't just
give up what's the response is quit so
it's about economy so you quit your
throw in the towel you give up you do
nothing any rights back and calls me a
right-wing idiot meanwhile Donald isn't
doing anything he's not making a
contributions community he's not running
the business he's not making any money
and as long as he blames the economy but
his business being so poor
then he's never going to get anywhere
he's never going to be a great
entrepreneur bad thing is going to
happen to your business you can't blame
other people and other circumstances you
have to fix it it's on you the cavalry
is not coming it's up to you to realize
that this is your responsibility to fix
I reminded of a story of Milton Hershey
one of my favorite our trainers from the
Hershey Chocolate Company and when he
started his business he borrowed a
couple hundred boxes aunt in
Philadelphia and he started he's working
15 16 hours a day making his products at
home at night and then selling them on
the street during the day this company
failed in Philadelphia so moved to New
Orleans it failed there was a Chicago it
failed their smooth in New York and it
failed there when a bunch of kids stole
all of his inventory and his money and
he had to come home a failure and he
went back to his house and his parents
said we don't want to know you you're
not part of our family anywhere we
disown you you're your failure you are
not part of our family and the only
thing her she could do was go for the
couch of one of his former employees and
sleep on that couch for a little while
well they continued to build his
business her she was successful because
he didn't blame the things around him he
could have had a ton of things to blame
on right the economy wasn't great this
customers weren't great the city that he
was at weren't great blame those those
case in New York who stole everything
from him blame his family was not
supporting him he had tons of reasons to
throw in a towel and to blame everybody
else for his inability to build a
successful business but he didn't he
kept going he knew that even though we
had all these hardships throwing a
demand we're all going to have these in
our life in our business it's not easy
even though we had all these hardships
thrown at him he kept going he realized
that was up to him to make this happen
so this is on you and I don't want to
hear you blaming other people your
family your lack of resources the
economy
once you realize that this is up to you
to be better that it's on you to turn
this business around when you accept
responsibility for it good things will
start to happen your mindset shift your
business will start to grow in your life
will get a lot better as well I want to
get to the calls i have Diana on the
line Diana where are you from and how
can I help hey I am some Utah Utah
alright well I know the program what's
going on Thanks well I am a massage
therapist and I decided to go and see
the business for myself so I just own my
own little home massage business just by
myself okay brand I find that you are
exactly right you know I used to blame
the economy and say people are just not
showing out some massage anymore but I
find that that's not really true because
you know everyone's trying to be more
healthy nowadays and so I realize that
it's just because I haven't been as
proactive as I need to be yes you know
getting people together and marketing so
I was wondering if you could give me
some cost effective marketing ideas to
get my name out there so I can get more
clients health so for congratulations on
getting this business started for a
company like yours referrals are really
important right there like how many
people can use service at a time in your
company per week oh um two-week well I
do you know sometimes about five or six
and thousands a day because they're
about an hour long so if I work you know
five to seven days that that's five
people a day so they are not imagine the
number is not huge hit 25 or 30 regular
customers is not a big number we're not
talking about I need thousands of people
that come visit my store right right so
it's figuring out how to build word of
mouth now are you getting referrals from
your current customers um yes as far as
I am aware I do I try to run deal for
the same you first someone to me that
they get like maybe half off a massage
but you know sometimes it's just they
they tell me that their friends can't
afford a massage at the moment sir it's
always the money thing right
so what I love to do in terms of getting
referrals I don't often go out and ask
the referrals because I finally put
people on the spot and it makes them
awkward and people give referrals is
because they genuinely want to instead
of getting some kind of discount on it
hey but you have to make it easy for
people to talk about your business and
over-deliver like crazy so what I would
think about doing is giving them a
reason to stand out beyond just your
massage so what do you do that's
different what's really special about
your business that people can talk about
okay so um the fact that maybe I'm
skilled in many different areas
modalities even and like energy work are
they signing up for that yeah a lot of
people actually don't know what some of
the modalities are but when I explain it
to them when they're here then they tend
to understand and they and really enjoy
it once I do it okay so you have a
holistic approach that's different than
other people okay and that has to be
clearly communicated to make it easy for
them so with every customer you want to
try to figure out how to give a little
bit more than what they signed up for
okay make them feel like they're getting
incredible value even if it doesn't cost
you anything that they're getting
incredible value from you that they
don't get from of anybody else you would
think about I can you write up a
document or a checklist for them to go
home and work on or can you give them
you know music song selection that you
really like that relaxes you anything
like that the movie doesn't cost you a
lot of time or money but it's just a
little extra stuff because now you're so
different than all the other massage
therapists out there ok I wanna I'm an
investor in a salsa dance company and
one of the things that we do just stayin
out again server type of business you
have to over-deliver like crazy is we
will send them a list of the move that
we've done in the class break it down
we'll give them videos of what they've
learned so they can practice will give
them sample songs for them to practice
too so when they go home they can take
in practice will do events for them to
come out to so they can practice their
dancing
nobody else does that and so we've stood
out and now we bring five six thousand
people a year to learn salsa from us
okay um so would it be a good idea maybe
to research other massage therapist
around the area and find out what
they're doing so that i can make sure
and definitely in the stepping outside
the box that's a good idea that the
problem is most massage therapists are
not great entrepreneurs and so you're
comparing yourself to mediocrity okay I
would try to find who's the best massage
therapist in the world look who's the
best in America was getting all the
business and what are they doing that's
different how can you bring that the
Utah okay okay there's that help yeah
that is that's perfect i appreciate it
good i'm excited for you okay good thank
you so much you have a great day all
right you too I think you listening if
you want to give her a lifeline of any
service kind of business you have to
look at ways for you to stand out over
deliver on the value things don't have
to cost you a lot of time or money just
put in a little extra bit to get people
to spending business your way and you
need go all in with your business now I
had this problem yesterday I've been
working on this book deal and I've never
really been at the book deal since I had
my website a number of companies have
come out me wanting to do a book deal
and I didn't need the ego boost I didn't
need it to open doors so that had the
power of my website and you don't make a
lot of money on books but my agent said
I need to have a book as part of his
plan so fine I said Steve he's my agent
Steve go get me a deal get me a company
a publisher who's going to pay me up
front to write the book and who will
commit to marketing this thing but
doesn't just sit and dine the shelf and
I'll go and write the book and he went
he did a great job when he found me one
of the top book agent in America has
done lots of work with great people who
you'd all recognize and she wanted a
proposal and a sample chapter and I
started writing the sample chapter I
didn't have anything ready to go and I
didn't commit to it the sample chapter I
just pulled together some resources I
had you know mage and Steve were a
little bit of it and it wasn't great it
was okay
but it wasn't great and the feedback
came back from from the agent like this
sucks I can't sell this this is not a
book and the problem was it in commit to
it I had to make a decision do I commit
to this do I make this happen or do I
give it up because if you do something
half-assed you're never going to get
great results and the same thing applies
to your business I decided to go for so
I'm going to spend the time and make
that sample chapter great and go get my
book deal with your business you have to
the side of it's important you have to
decide if you're going to commit to it
and bring your passion and energy and
excitement and give it your best if you
do it half ass you're never going to be
a great entrepreneur you're never going
to achieve great results and we all have
those projects in our business that are
just lingering you need to either put it
into it put your energy into it make
those things awesome or dump them and
work on something else I have amber on
the line amber where are you from and
how can I help I'm from the New York
metro area New York all right good NYC
what's going on how can I help oh well I
have all a few questions Evan recently
you like about a half a year ago I
decided to leave my job and I was
looking into starting different types of
businesses okay and you know I decided
upon a house you know cleaning out a
cleaning houses this private house
cleaning okay and you know it went you
know and it started off you know with
just myself and I was doing fairly well
and recently I've been doing very well
great and I had hired a lot more people
to help me sure so I have about ten
employees I say about after them a full
time and half of them apart time awesome
I don't know I wanna know how I would go
about registering this business number
one another too much the best way to pay
my employees so you need to get this
business what is it now is it just under
your personal name correct okay there's
huge liability issues here so I mean I'm
not a lawyer but you should definitely
talk to one if one of your employees
gets in the chocolate for whatever
reason they
feel something or something happens at
one of the houses if not it owner sues
you it's personal like they could take
your house okay hope you that's
important to know that that's important
you something yes I children your arms
by boat okay I don't cost a lot of money
you just go and set it up you could talk
to Lori to help you figure that out but
it doesn't cost law and it's bad that is
like super important okay how are you
paying employees now is it is it Josh or
what are youcome cash right now okay I
don't want you to tell me the name of
your company cuz you can get in trouble
all right okay like are you filing taxes
uh well I'm yeah i just started actually
okay yes this is important okay because
if the government comes after you there
are huge penalties here so you have to
do things properly and i know a lot of
times the cleaning business is the cash
out of business but if you're not
recording it and they're not they're not
you know submitting their money to the
government's been here so much i made if
the government finds out does it come
down hard on you but also on them so you
have to like congratulations are getting
this started this is great to you
problem nothing to keep quitting your
job and you have 10 people working for
you I love that success stories but you
also have to mal like this is important
I don't want you to have all that taken
away from you and and everything else in
your personal side the setting up of
business is not hard it's really it's
fast and easy sign a few papers and it's
done but you have to figure out the
whole payment system they become
employees of your business they see you
have to you pay them bi-weekly or
whatever it is file their taxes you pay
you know your taxes properly but if you
ever get audited you are not on the hook
because they could take it like its
think your business okay yeah so you
saying take care of the tax in register
the business registered the business for
sure any insurance that that was the
other issue yeah insurance too but if
something happened but if your employee
you're lucky to nothing the top
yes right I know you saw me like rather
stealing you know where were like what
if you're rich themselves on the job
correct like suitability what's it
happen already no nothing's happened yet
okay that's good we don't want to rely
on Lady Luck here right right no no
absolutely not and since I ain't going
quickly I need to know these things yeah
and you know what sit down with the
local lawyer you can figure all of that
out in half an hour really it's not hard
I mean it may seem hard because he's
never done it before but it's not hard
it's really easy to get all that set up
and it's so important because you don't
want your business to go under okay can
you do that next week I can I can do it
I remember good luck congrats in the
business for thank you very much of it
no problem for all you listen and hey
it's so important you gotta cross the
t's and dot your i's and I know a lot of
you may not be great at all the
paperwork and you've men and the legal
stuff but that's important stuff to get
figured out get a lawyer on your team
part time obviously when you need them
if you got to get all those things taken
care of because I can sink your business
that's it for me today I've had a blast
thank you so much to Steve and Fernanda
for all the great work today nothing
went wrong so it's great i love you guys
i'm on in two weeks i look forward to
hearing from you again good luck and
growing your business stay focused stay
hungry and i'll see you soon